talk to me about how
right justification so this perfect
block
and left justification which allows this
ragged just ragged right
comes into it like could are you saying
a kindle can have right justification
blocks and be beautifully laid out if
the algorithm is good enough yes
the problem you have in terms of
lengthening if we go back to what we had
originally so if we put the okay this
line has okay i'll sort it out for you
this is the what i call the brady
debacle layout yep all right it's a
well-known uh layout algorithm yes and
it took me a long time too you wouldn't
want me calculating every time you
turned a page on your kindle all right
so if we wanted to make this fill the
width of the page i mean we've got an
obvious problem with line two and that
we've only got one word on it
but for line one we could make it fill
the width of the page to make it what
we'd call fully justified and the way we
do that is we can just move the
characters out and increase the spacing
between so we make the space and it's
bigger and increase the spacing of these
so that's we could do that but i think
in this case it's getting to the point
where it's really not pleasant to read
this insufficient characters and
insufficient
to get a nice layout so we'd probably
have to leave that or we might decide to
move has down
and so on so we can adjust the spacing
between each characters we can adjust
the spacing between the words how about
this one how about this one steve
what do you think
so that's probably a a nicer layout than
having insufficient splurdau but it's
still pretty nasty so i mean these are
problems that they had in newspapers and
when they were newspapers they would
come across this problem and they had
the hot the hot metal well even these
days with desktop publishing but the
advantage they have there is because
they don't know when they're doing it
once they can see
that there is a problem here and they
can think well actually
this line has insufficient length it's
never going to break nicely let's let's
add an extra word in or
change it steve there's one thing we
haven't done yet that i'm sure all the
viewers are going to be screaming at the
screen
and i'm sure you're about to ask me
about it but i'll preempt
what about doing this
and putting in a
putting in a hyphen where would the
hyphen go down this side
on the side here yeah there we go
what about that
so yep that's that's something else we
could do but again we then have to start
thinking you've now just increased the
number of places where you can break
words so you've got even more versions
to consider so the poor cpu and the
kindle is going oh no you've given me
even more work absolutely
and also there's a there's an even
bigger problem now in that if you're not
careful when hyphenating things you can
have
unintended consequences when you try
typesetting this line has insufficient
length therapists therapists let's go
you're probably gonna have to steal a
name let's steal an agent yeah
so here we go
there's the word
i can see what you're gonna do to me
here already you've got a p we wanna pee
we got one here and uh what are these
tiles by the way steve they're not
they're they're not scrambled so this is
a game called banana grounds which is
similar to uh scrabble other word-based
games are available
so yeah yeah so say say we had the word
therapist coming at the end here
so if i got myself into a pickle with
the word therapist here and i wanted to
hyphenate what you're saying is i could
accidentally hyphenate hyphenate there
and we draw draw my hyphen here
and suddenly someone has gone from being
a therapist to something that they
definitely wouldn't want to be they are
the rapist and so this actually happened
in a newspaper i believe and so they
were sued quite rightly for the
defamation of character so they were
referring to like bill jones they're
and they call him bill jones the rapist
exactly the eye sees the two words and
so you have to be very careful and you
have to program that in and you can also
look unsightly so for example you don't
want to just have a single character
you're increasing the amount of
calculations that the computer has to do
to do that so it looks like a very
simple problem and it sounds like you
think
typesetting text that's really really
simple but then when you start to think
about it and particularly to get a nice
looking layout which you want when
you're reading you don't want to be you
don't want to be as your friend cp gray
is found you don't want to be looking at
the time setting when reading a novel
you want to be enjoying the story
and so it it's something that disappears
into the background but it's actually
quite complicated for the computer to do
we should give the kindle
less of a hard time i think so it's
working harder than i think yeah
i think so
all right
i i can tell you my friend won't be
convinced
but
it's interesting and i have new respect
for what my e-reader has to do